[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen es ist wie so oft in
Europa zwischendurchbruch und scheitern
liegt ein Gipfel der Überstunden machen
musste Brüssel heute abend beides war
möglich Durchbruch und scheitern und es
stand viel auf dem Spiel europa braucht
eine Antwort auf den multivums aus den
USA die milliardenschwere Subventionen
auf den Tisch legen für Klimaschutz und
Sozialpolitik Europa will sich dringend
auf einen gemeinsamen Deckel beim
Gaspreis einigen hatte das in den
vergangenen Wochen nicht geschafft und
auch Milliarden Pakete die eigentlich
geklärt sein sollten wie die Ukraine
helfen standen plötzlich wieder neuen
Frage Europa hat also einiges zu klären
und zwar schnell Isabel Schäfers
es ist dieser Gast der Europas Führung
immer wieder vor Augen führt wie ernst
die Lage ist der ukrainische Präsident
selenski fordert heute mehr
Unterstützung für sein Land doch zu
Beginn des Tages sah es so aus als würde
dieser Gipfel das nicht liefern können
Polen blockierte die versprochenen 18
Milliarden für die Ukraine weil im Deal
auch die Zustimmung zur globalen
Mindeststeuer vorgesehen ist
blackmail das ist Erpressung von manchen
Ländern dass sie versuchen ihre Themen
durchzusetzen die gar nichts miteinander
zu tun haben
wir befürchten dass wir immer langsamer
werden bei der Entscheidungsfindung wir
geraten derzeit geradezu in gegenseitige
nun ja wie soll man es nennen nicht
endende erpressungspartys
nachdem diese Woche bereits Ungarns
Blockade gelöst wurde schafft es die
Runde wohl letztlich auch Polen zu
überzeugen und so werden die
optimistischen Aussichten vom morgen
wohl doch Realität
wir werden heute die 18 Milliardenhilfe
für die Ukraine freigeben das ist ein
sehr wichtiger Punkt und wir diskutieren
ein neues Sanktionspaket auch neue
Sanktionen gegen Russland sind durch
aber die Einigkeit endet hier in Brüssel
meist da wo die Details beginnen und so
bleibt ein Thema weiter ungelöst der
gaspreisdeckel die Gegner befürchten
dass durch eine Preisobergrenze beim
Gaseinkauf nicht mehr genug Gas in
Europa ankommt
für uns sind Garantien wichtig wie
kommen wir raus falls der Deckel schief
geht falls die Tanker wegfahren aus
Europa
wir werden fünf Stunden diskutieren und
die Aufgabe dann an die Energieminister
zurückgeben so läuft das seit sechs
Monaten
und genau so kam es dann auch eine
Annäherung ja aber wieder keine
Entscheidung dabei könnten die Deckel
Befürworter die Skeptiker einfach
überstimmen doch der erste
deckelskeptiker will diese Möglichkeit
gar nicht sehen ich war immer klar dass
wir eine einvernehmliche Lösung
anstreben und sehr gute Meldung dass wir
kurz davor sind kurz davor aber eben
nicht am Ziel die Energieminister müssen
am Montag die Höhe des Deckels noch
festlegen und Deutschland notfalls
überstimmen auch am Ende dieses Jahres
ringt Europa weiter um Details und um
Einigkeit
ja eine Union in der das Wort Erpressung
dann doch erstaunlich häufig benutzt
wurde heute ultra unser Mann in Brüssel
genannt Ulf das ist das wahr
möglicherweise das große Streit Thema
was wir da gerade gehört haben der
preisdeckel für Gas die Deutschen haben
kräftig gebremst diese Lösung die sich
da jetzt offenbar abzeichnet was heißt
denn die für Deutschland
als ich glaube was ganz wichtig eben ist
für die Bundesregierung und dafür hat
sie monatelang gekämpft dass eben kein
Preis festgesetzt wird in Europa der die
Gefahr birgt dass sie dann kein Gas mehr
auf dem Weltmarkt bekommen werden
dagegen wird die Bundesregierung weiter
kämpfen und es sieht so aus dass man
jetzt ein klassischen Kompromiss Macht
in Europa man wird einen gaspreisdeckel
festlegen also einen Preis aber und das
ist eben ganz wichtig für die
Bundesregierung diesen Deckel dann auch
wieder ein bisschen entschärfen indem
man sagt wenn dieser Preis den Europa
festgelegt hat einfach eben nicht mit
dem Weltmarktpreis übereinstimmt wenn
der Weltmarktpreis höher ist dann kann
man Ausnahmen haben und dann kann die
Bundesregierung eben doch Gas bekommen
somit wäre quasi ein klassischer
Kompromiss geschafft die einen können
sagen es gibt diesen gaspreisdeckel und
die anderen spricht die Bundesregierung
kann sagen wir bekommen trotzdem Gas und
du bleibst noch im Moment bei uns bitte
denn wir haben noch ein weiteres
europäisches Thema denn da liegt noch
der böse Verdacht der Korruption im Raum
der Skandal im Europaparlament hat
längst den EU-Gipfel erreicht und
überschattet ihn einer der Verdächtigen
rund um Taschen voller
bestechungsmillionen in kleinen Scheinen
soll ein Geständnis abgelegt haben aber
zu viel bleibt noch mysteriös für was
genau war ein Scheichtum am Golf
offenbar bereit so viel zu bezahlen wer
steckt noch mit drin und kann Europa
genau jetzt ein Luftverkehrsabkommen
umsetzen das Katar und seiner Staats
Airline viele Vorteile bringt florian
neuhahn hat Details dazu
wenn man alles andere ausblendet dann
kann man natürlich als französischer
Präsident bestens gelaunt nach Katar
Reisen für ein Halbfinale der
Nationalmannschaft für ein Bad in der
Menge und für Küsschen mit dem Emil wenn
man am nächsten Morgen wieder in Europa
ist beim EU-Gipfel kommen die
unangenehmen Fragen trotzdem hat das
selbe Katha EU-Politiker bestochen voilà
Mission der Präsident und sein Versuch
ein Thema loszuwerden
Leser die zuständigen Stellen werden
entsprechend entscheiden auf Grundlage
von Tatsachen
so einfach geht das Thema aber nicht weg
wenige Kilometer entfernt sitzt eine
mittlerweile ehemalige Vizepräsidentin
des EU-Parlaments in Untersuchungshaft
Eva Kai die europäische
Staatsanwaltschaft verdächtigt sie und
eine weitere Abgeordnete nun auch noch
des Betrugs mit EU-Geldern und der
belgische lesbare berichtet caillis
Freund habe gestanden sie hätten Geld
angenommen von Katha und von Marokko um
europäische Politik zu beeinflussen es
ist die Präsidentin des EU-Parlaments
die mal wieder Scherben zusammenkehren
muss
dieses Strafverfahren beschädigt unsere
Demokratie Europa alles wofür wir stehen
Vertrauen das über Jahre gewachsen und
in wenigen Momenten zerstört worden ist
muss wieder aufgebaut werden diese
Arbeit beginnt jetzt jetzt
Starts now wir haben leider in der
Vergangenheit bei vorherigen Skandalen
gesehen dass die Bereitschaft wirklich
auch Veränderungen herbeizuführen dass
die nach den Skandalen sobald die
öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit weg ist
rapide abnimmt noch aber schauen alle
hin und so geht es heute im EU-Parlament
um strengere Regeln etwa für Kontakte
mit anderen Staaten und um den
Flugverkehr um ein Luftverkehrsabkommen
mit Qatar das
Qatar Airways Jahr für Jahr mehr Zugang
zum Milliardenmarkt Europa gewährt 2021
beschlossen doch jetzt hat ein ganzes
Parlament Bauchschmerzen es gibt den
Verdacht dass massiv mit äh finanzieller
mit finanziellem Aufwand das geschmiert
worden ist dieser Korruptionsverdacht
wiegt schwer und insofern müssen alle
Dinge die wirtschaftlich jetzt mit
Parteien in Verbindung gebracht werden
sei es Handel sei es Luftverkehr
überprüft werden alles überprüfen etwa
auch die gerade geschlossenen gasdeals
mit
katata der deutsche Bundeskanzler und
sein Versuch das lästige
korruptionsthema von allem anderen
fernzuhalten
das ist ein Thema für sich und das muss
für sich aufgeklärt werden weil wir das
niemals nicht akzeptieren können es ist
der Versuch eine scharfe Grenze zu
ziehen hier die kleine Affäre dort die
große Realpolitik diese Grenze aber
verschwimmt
Ulf ist eine Einschätzung wie groß ist
die Angst heute Abend in Brüssel dass
dieser korruptions-skandal noch viel
größere Ausmaße annehmen könnte
also wenn man mit eu-abgeordnet spricht
dann kann man deutlich sehen dass es
Angst gibt da fällt auch das Wort dass
das vielleicht sogar systemisch ist vor
allem weil immer wieder neue Vorwürfe
von Verdächtigungen bekannt werden jetzt
hat sich der Skandal ausgeweitet und es
gibt ein neues Land mit Marokko und es
gibt ja auch eine neue Abgeordnete die
verdächtigt wird diesmal von den
Konservativen warum die Abgeordneten
Parlament zur besorgt sind ist weil die
Behörden wirklich wohl ein sehr
akribischen Job gemacht haben über ein
Jahr lang hat die belgische Stadt der
Staatssicherheit dient wirklich
Forschung Recherchen und Beobachtung
angestellt im Zusammenspiel mit sechs
weiteren Geheimdiensten von
ausländischen Diensten und da ist so
viel Daten zusammengekommen die jetzt
langsam ausgewertet werden dass man eben
fürchtet man hat ein systemisches
Problem einer der Mittler soll gesagt
haben folgen wir dem Geld ein berühmter
Satz vollloser Manni der ist damals
gefallen bei dem großen Skandal
Watergate-Affäre in Amerika ob so groß
wird weiß man nicht aber die Sorgen sind
jedenfalls immens follow the money auch
ein wichtiger journalistischer Spruch
wir bleiben dran Ulf herzlichen Dank
ulfräule war das ZDF Brüssel an der
ehrwürdigen Berliner Uniklinik Charité
ist bereits Weihnachten und das ist
keine gute Nachricht das Krankenhaus
geht vorzeitig in den feiertagsmodus
weil der Personalmangel keine andere
Lösung zulässt erschöpfte
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter viele
selbst krank alle verschiebbaren
Operationen des Jahresende sind abgesagt
ein Wahnsinn was in diesem Winter los
ist sagt ein Kinderarzt denn überall in
Deutschland häufen sich die
alarmnachrichten aus dem
Gesundheitssystem
Notfallrettung am Limit Krankenhäuser
ohne freie Betten und jetzt Apotheken
die nicht liefern können Britta
Spiekermann berichtet
die Berliner Charité Tritt auf die
Bremse ab kommenden Montag nur noch
Notbetrieb alle nicht unbedingt
notwendigen Behandlungen müssen
verschoben werden eine gravierende
Entscheidung für die Uniklinik eine
schmerzhafte für Patientin und Patienten
jetzt heißt es in der Charité Kräfte
konzentrieren auf die Notfallversorgung
und die Not ist groß nicht nur in vielen
Kliniken auch in der Berliner
Kinderarztpraxis von Jakob Maske jeden
Tag 100 kranke Kinder und Jugendliche
mindestens
was aber völlig neu ist ist dass wir die
Kinder die wirklich schwer krank sind in
den Kliniken nicht mehr unterbringen
können diese Kinder werden häufig aus
den großen Städten heraus in andere
Kliniken verlegt über hunderte von
Kilometern mittlerweile und das ist eine
Gefahr für die Kindergesundheit und wird
auch eine Gefahr für Kinder leben sein
wie konnte es soweit kommen im Bundestag
ist die Linkspartei so sauer dass er
eine Aktuelle Stunde beantragt nicht nur
sie hat Redebedarf mit dem Minister es
wird ein scharfer Wind
wir brauchen Anreize dass die
Beschäftigten zurückkommen in die
Krankenhäuser und für Kinder da zu sein
Kinder die sich nicht an Fallpauschalen
berechnen lassen sondern die einfach nur
gesund werden wollen Lauterbach hat eine
Reform vorgeschlagen Revolution nennt er
sie in der akuten Lage sagt er ab
nächstem Jahr weg mit den Fallpauschalen
in der Kindermedizin und dem schlimmsten
Fall Konsequenzen für kranke Erwachsene
nicht nur in Berlin wir werden alle
Eingriffe zur Not verschieben bei
Erwachsenen um den Kindern alles
anzubieten was wir anbieten können wir
lassen hier kein Kind zurück die CDU
lange selbst in Regierungsverantwortung
holt aus und zeigt dabei doch auch auf
sich selbst
ich bin bei Ihnen dass wir vieles
verändern müssen aber hören Sie bitte
auf immer so zu tun als sind sie die
letzten Jahre nicht dabei gewesen vieles
erinnert an die schlimmsten
pandemiezeiten und es ist auch so dass
karl-team-klinikum in Cottbus das größte
Krankenhaus in Brandenburg alle nicht
lebensnotwendigen Operationen werden
seit heute verschoben kranke Menschen
treffen auch hier auf ein krankes System
eine große klinikreform in den
vergangenen Jahren gab es nicht auch die
einzelnen Bundesländer hätten mehr
investieren müssen taten es aber selten
ein ganzes System droht aus dem Ruder zu
laufen mit massiven Folgen bis hin zum
Fiebersaft für Kinder die eugen-apotheke
in München hier sind heute 200
Medikamente nicht lieferbar zum einen
ist wirklich seit langer Zeit des
Gesundheitssystem definitiv kaputt
gespart worden durch die ganzen
Rabattverträge die Firmen haben reagiert
haben ihre ganzen Produktionen ins
Ausland verlegt Abhängigkeiten von China
und Indien unterbrochene Lieferketten
spürbare Bruchstellen Karl Lauterbach
will viele Reformen für die Kliniken
gegen die Lieferengpässe bei
Medikamenten es bleibt nicht viel Zeit
und er will mehr als nur kleine
Korrekturen
und dann im Deutschen Bundestag heute
auch ein Rekord 50 Jahre ununterbrochen
im deutschen Parlament das hat vor
Wolfgang Schäuble noch niemand geschafft
er wolle sich mit ungebetenen
Ratschlägen zurückhalten sagt der
jahrzehntelange Abgeordnete für den
Wahlkreis 284 Offenburg und gibt dann
doch einen einen der dieses Land
voranbringen soll wie wäre es wenn wir
eine breite öffentliche Debatte anstoßen
würden wie wir unseren durch
perfektionistische Überregulierung
ähnlich dem gefesselten riesen Gulliver
in zu vielen fast schon handlungsunfähig
gewordenen Staat durch eine grundlegende
Neuordnung der Aufgaben auch zwischen
Staat und Gesellschaft wieder
effizienter machen können
spricht einer aus Erfahrung und aus
Sorge und in der Hoffnung dass
Deutschland ihn hört
Hannah jetzt du mit den
Nachrichtenübersicht heute und da geht
es zuallererst um die Gas und
strompreisbremse die eine wichtige Hürde
genommen hat der Bundestag stimmte heute
für das milliardenschwere
gesetzespaketen mit dem die hohen
Energiekosten abgefedert werden sollen
für Privathaushalte sowie kleine und
mittlere Unternehmen soll ein
preisdeckel für 80 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs gelten dieser kommt
ab März und gilt auch rückwirkend für
Januar und Februar für Strom müssen dann
maximal 40 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
gezahlt werden für Gas sind es 12 morgen
muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen
vor einer deutlichen Verschlechterung
der humanitären Lage in der Ukraine hat
UNO menschenrechtskommissar Volker Turk
gewarnt sollten die russischen
Luftangriffe auf die Infrastruktur des
Landes anhalten könnte dies zu weiteren
Vertreibungen führen sagte er nach
seiner Reise in die Ukraine dort trafen
russische Angriffe heute unter anderem
die Stadt rakev dabei wurde ein
Lagerhauskomplex zerstört der nach
ukrainischen Angaben rein zivil genutzt
wurde
der Rüstungskonzern Rheinmetall baut
seine munitionsherstellung aus und zwar
mit einer neuen Anlage in Deutschland
ziel ist die Bundeswehr dadurch
unabhängiger von ausländischen
Fertigungsstätten zu machen zuletzt
hatte ein Nein der Schweiz zu deutschen
munitionslieferungen an die Ukraine in
Berlin für Verärgerung gesorgt
Rheinmetall verwies außerdem auf Lücken
in den deutschen munitionsbeständen die
geschlossen werden müssten um die
Vorgaben der NATO zu erfüllen
der Einsatz der Bundeswehr in Mali soll
im Mai 2024 Enden das Engagement bis
dahin knüpft die Bundesregierung an
Bedingungen und die waren heute Thema
beim Besuch von Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht in dem westafrikanischen Land
die forderte von der Militär unter den
Fahrplan für die Präsidentschaftswahlen
einzuhalten und die Bundeswehr beim
Schutz der Bevölkerung nicht zu
behindern das war seit der
Machtübernahme des Militärs in Mali
mehrfach der Fall
10.000 Pflegekräfte in britischen
Krankenhäusern haben heute für zwölf
Stunden ihre Arbeit niedergelegt und so
den Druck auf die britische Regierung zu
erhöhen diese bietet Ihnen drei Prozent
mehr Lohn und eine Einmalzahlung
Gewerkschaft fordert dagegen einen
Abschluss deutlich über der
Inflationsrate die im November bei fast
11 Prozent lag es ist der erste groß
angelegte Streik in der 106 jährigen
Geschichte der Gewerkschaft
an den Zinsen drehen ist eine delikate
Angelegenheit denn so etwas führt immer
zugleich mehreren Effekten von denen man
manche will und manche eben gerade nicht
ein Balanceakt also auch heute wieder
für die Europäische Zentralbank
Inflation in den Griff bekommen aber
Wirtschaft nicht abwirken das ist die
Herausforderung
0,5% Punkte hoch das ist das Mittel der
Wahl jetzt für die EURO Währungshüter
den Folgen für uns alle geht Isabelle
überall integriert in die Karosserie
Thorsten kiedel glaubt fest an dieses
Projekt ein Elektroauto das sich selbst
aufladen kann an neuen Prototypen bauen
Sie hier in der Münchner berghalle der
sie und könnte bald in Serie gehen es
gibt 21.000 Reservierungen und ein
Problem Geld es ist mit steigenden
Zinsen teurer geworden das Unternehmen
braucht aber 130 Millionen Euro um
weiter zu machen wir sind auf Piraten
wir sind circa ein Jahr vor
produktionsstaat und jetzt an kein
weiteres Kapital zu kommen das heißt das
eine Innovation die patentiert ist
verloren gehen würde das trifft uns es
würde uns treffen wie viele andere
Startups und Wachstumsunternehmen in
Deutschland die Europäische Zentralbank
hat den Leitzins abermals angehoben um
0,5% Punkte
have to rise significently die Zinssätze
müssen weiter deutlich und stetig
steigen um ein Niveau zu erreichen das
ausreicht für eine Rückkehr zu unserem
Inflationsziel von 2 %
die EZB erhöht die Zinsen um die
Inflation zu dämpfen die Preissteigerung
ist tatsächlich leicht zurückgegangen
allerdings auf hohem Niveau die
Kehrseite das Geld sitzt bei den
Investoren weniger locker und die Zinsen
für Unternehmenskredite steigen bereits
deutlich warnende Stimmen
in der jetzigen Situation mit einer
bevorstehenden Rezession mit deutlich
auch einer langsam zurück in den
Inflationsrate wer die EZB Meinung nach
gut beraten auch ganz kurz abzuwarten
vielleicht eine Pause zu machen bei den
Zinserhöhungen und im nächsten Frühjahr
sich dann noch mal zu entscheiden ob man
es nötig um weiterzumachen oder nicht es
gibt zwei Lager jene die weiter
steigende Zinsen fürchten weil sie zu
einer Wirtschaftskrise führen könnten
und jene die noch deutlich höhere Zinsen
fordern mit dem abschreckenden Beispiel
der USA in den 60ern die lange mit einer
Inflation zu kämpfen hatten die
Amerikaner haben zu lange gewartet zu
zögerlich haben immer gehofft das
Problem der Inflation löst sich
irgendwie von alleine und am Ende war
das inflationsproblem so ausgeprägt dass
sie amerikanischen Notenbank nur
Vollbremsung hinlegen musste sie musste
den Leitzins bis auf 20% anheben sie
musste eine doppelt Rezession anfangen
der 80er Jahre auslösen um dieses
tiefgreifende inflationsproblem zu lösen
um ihr Elektroauto und die 300 daran
hängenden Arbeitsplätze zu retten hat
das Start-up jetzt eine Kampagne
gestartet kommen genügend Bestellungen
und Anzahlungen zusammen hat das
Solarauto unabhängig vom Thema Zinsen
eine Chance
die EZB hat den Leitzins also zum
vierten Mal in diesem Jahr angehoben mit
dem Ziel die hohe Inflation auszubremsen
und darauf wollen wir jetzt noch mal
genauer schauen Valerie Haller in
Frankfurt noch liegt die Teuerungsrate
ja bei 10% obwohl mehrfach an der
Zinsschraube gedreht wurde wann ist denn
mit einem spürbaren Rückgang der
Inflation zu rechnen also könnte sein
dass immerhin der Höhepunkt der
Inflation schon erreicht ist vor allem
weil Strom und Gaspreis
bremsen die Teuerung eine Zeit lang
drücken dürfen bis die Inflation aber
durchgreifen zurückgeht da das wird wohl
noch dauern die EZB rechnet sogar bis 20
25 mit erhöhter Inflation die sozialen
Folgen die sind gravieren während die
Inflation Frist Gehalt sie frisst
Erspartes und kostet Kaufkraft Job der
Notenbanken ist es dass sie sich nicht
dauerhaft auf hohem Niveau festsetzt
diesen Job geht die EZB nach langen
zögern offenbar jetzt an wir haben dann
die Märkte heute auf die
Zinsentscheidung reagiert mit einem
kräftigen Kurs Rutsch weil die EZB ja
ganz deutlich signalisiert hat das noch
weitere Zinserhöhungen anstehen außerdem
hat sie ihre Wachstumsprognose für den
Euroraum gesenkt der DAX heute also tief
im Minus mit über drei Prozent und
wieder unter 14.000 Punkten fünf
Notenbanken haben die Zinsen in den
vergangenen beiden Tagen angehoben neben
der EZB auch die amerikanische die
norwegische die britische und die
schweizerische die Notenbanken sind sich
also einig die hohe Inflation haben sie
noch längst nicht im Griff vielen Dank
Valerie für diese Einordnung
zum Wintersport da hat es Benedikt doll
heute beim Biathlon Weltcup in
Frankreich aufs Podest geschafft der
32-Jährige sicherte sich im Sprint den
dritten Platz an fehlerfreiem schießen
und einer starken Laufleistung auf Rang
1 landete der Norweger Johannes Böll und
zweiter wurdest durla Holm lehrgerät
ebenfalls Norweger
extennisprofi Boris Becker ist wieder
ein freier Mann der 55-Jährige ist in
Großbritannien aus dem Gefängnis
entlassen worden und nach Deutschland
ausgereist im April war Bäcker wegen
Insolvenzverschleppung zu zweieinhalb
Jahren Haft verurteilt worden eine
britische Sonderregel ermöglicht eine
vorzeitige Entlassung von Straffälligen
Ausländern wenn diese direkt abgeschoben
werden
und noch eine wichtige Unwetterwarnung
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes vor
Glatteis in Teilen von Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg
2022 was für ein Jahr sollen wir das
abhaken und voll auf das kommende setzen
wollen wir da wirklich zurück gucken
wollen wir wenn es wie man es unter je
machen
tja 2022 geht zu Ende Zeit Bilanz zu
ziehen also was soll man mit Blick auf
dieses Jahr sagen es tut uns leid
es tut mir leid auch Herr Söder im
Rahmen der Möglichkeiten hat die
deutsche Politik doch eine solide
Leistung hingelegt whatever
das means naja das Meet das 2022 so
einiges über uns hereingebrochen ist
aber die Politik stand hilfreich an
unserer Seite Beispiel Energiesparen was
kann jede und jeder an seine Heizung
selbst einstellen einfach Form ins Bett
gehen den Thermostaten runter drehen
Wahnsinn und wir uns erst der Volker
Wissing erklärt hat warum ein Tempolimit
in Deutschland nicht möglich sein
so viele Schilder haben wir gar nicht
auf Lager hat gesagt ja schönen Dank
dafür aber bitte oder Corona da gab es
ja diesen ganz neuen wissenschaftlichen
Ansatz wir müssen das Lösen anders
kriegen das nicht gelöst jetzt klingt
jetzt erstmal komisch aber egal denn
morgen also diesen Punkt den werde ich
wieder ein kassieren wunderbar und den
Rest klären gewohnt konstruktiv die
Bundesländer unter sich aber oh Gott zu
tief bei der AFD da gab es konstruktive
das Herz der Partei schlägt heute sehr
weit rechts ja mit der schlussformte ist
ja auch noch nie eine afd-führungskraft
zurückgetreten das ist so wie früher
beim Camping ich vergleiche das immer so
da haben sie immer diejenigen beschwert
das ist nass im Zelt sind ist und es war
diejenigen die auch im Zelt
hineingepinkelt haben apropos Ekel
ja ja von wegen hurra wer hätte gedacht
dass so ein Milchgesicht mal die Welt in
Schrecken versetzen würde Krieg in
Europa 10.000 Tote und daran ist
wirklich nichts lustig aber der Eiertanz
den die Regierung in Sachen
Waffenlieferungen aufgeführt hat ich
weiß nicht warum der Kanzler Probleme
hat immer ein Wort das Wort Panzer in
den Mund zu nehmen oder schwere Waffen
ich verstehe es nicht naja weil wir nun
mal keine Panzer liefern sondern Waffen
mit erheblicher Auswirkungen zum
Beispiel den Gepard sieht zwar wie ein
Panzer aus
hört sich auch wie ein Panzer an aber
ist kein Panzer das ist der Unterschied
ist ein gutes Stichwort
[Musik]
was vergessen der Olaf Scholz herr
Scholz verfügt über ein inneres Geländer
der verfügt über ein Geländer aber kaum
über Erinnerungen an Gespräche mit der
Warburg Bank über das kriminelle cum-ex
System weil weil das System damit
verbunden ist dass ich dazu nichts weiß
wir lernen auch wenn mal einiges nicht
so gut läuft haben wir doch eine Chance
ja dass die Zukunft als na Möglichkeit
begriffen wird auf die man mit Hoffnung
setzen kann
ja dann kann 2023 ja kommen also
fröhlich bleiben
was für ein Jahr das volle Programm der
komplette satirische Jahresrückblick in
33 Minuten jederzeit zu sehen in der ZDF
Mediathek und auch die Kollegin Maybrit
Illner lässt dieses Jahr noch mal
vorüberziehen unter anderem mit Joachim
Gauck und Klaus Kleber das schauen wir
uns an und sind dann morgen an dieser
Stelle wieder für Sie da meldet sich
hier gegen 0 Uhr 43 mit unserem heute
journal Update 0 Uhr
stellen vom gesamten Team hier auch
hinter den Kameras
[Musik]
guten Abend Glatteis Regen breitet sich
auch in dieser Nacht aus vom Bodensee
über München weiter bis nach Passau im
Laufe der Nacht geht der Glatteis Regen
in Schnee über und so können hier zwei
bis zehn Zentimeter Neuschnee fallen und
einige Zentimeter neue Schnee gibt es
auch in Norddeutschland in der Mitte
Deutschlands aber ist es klar und da
wird es dann auch sehr kalt da sind die
Temperaturen zum Teil bis minus 14 Grad
morgen bleiben die Temperaturen meist im
leichten Dauerfrost und auch morgen
fällt noch Schnee besonders Richtung
Ober und Niederbayern einige
Schneeschauer gibt's auch in
Norddeutschland sonst wird das ein
freundlicher Freitag häufig mit
Sonnenschein das vierte
Adventswochenende bringt uns dann
Sonnenschein Nebel und Hochnebel bei
meist frostigen Temperaturen in der
Nacht zum Montag über Tag droht wieder
Glatteis Regen diesmal von Westen
damit unsere unwetterprognosen noch
besser werden hat die europäische
Raumfahrtagentur ESA einen
Wettersatelliten der dritten Generation
erfolgreich gestartet er wird mehr Daten
liefern als seine Vorgänger und
präzisere Daten sie genauer wir den
Ist-Zustand der Atmosphäre kennen desto
zuverlässiger werden die
Modellvorhersagen für die Zukunft Image
One hat daher mehrere Spezialkameras
deren Sensoren sind so empfindlich dass
sie sogar im Tageslicht Blitze erkennen
und dadurch exakte Gewitter und
sturmdaten liefern können gemeinsam mit
weiteren Hightech Satelliten die noch
ins All müssen beginnt auch bei der
Überwachung der Klimaveränderungen eine
neue
Ära guten Abend